Miley Cyrus reveals the one song she
doesn't like to perform anymore
wrecking off oh my gosh sorry guys
[Music]
I'll do it I'll do it but I don't love
it Wow I don't like when you're like so
stoked on something you're so happy and
then you have to go sing a song that's
about like a big bummer right you know
and then I can never live down that I
licked a sledgehammer
the malibu singer also opened up on KTU
radio morning show about her close
friendship with Katy Perry she has been
a friend of mine for a long time we were
actually just realizing that next year
we'll have been friends for 10 years I
think I might friend that I've known the
longest Maile says the two go way back
to her Disney Channel days in fact they
became friends when Katy wrote this in
2008
[Music]
when he came out with like kissed a girl
I was doing the Hannah Montana movie and
I heard her on the radio they said who'd
you write that about and she said me and
I was on a four-wheeler actually my dad
had this four-wheeler this help
hillbilly we are we got a radio like
attached to the four-wheeler and I heard
and I started screaming and freaking out
[Music]